this video is sponsored by wren hi
everybody welcome back to the channel if
you're a casual man carrying thing
watcher you may not know that i talk
about books also
when i read them despite how abnormally
busy i've been i
have read some great books this month
and i feel like i have to talk about
them one of them actually may be my new
favorite of all time can i say that is
that too soon i just read it so i'll
talk about that i read some good crime
fiction and i also just want to talk
about some of the books i've been
interested in books i want to read maybe
some of the books i dnf'd because i
didn't have enough time but i want to
get back to so there's a lot to talk
about hopefully you get some
recommendations out of this first and
foremost i'm eager to just talk about
this writer thank god i found her an
incredible writer that i feel like not
many people know about her but she was a
crime fiction writer who wrote
throughout the
the 40s and the 50s uh she wrote the
novels for in a lonely place which was
turned into a bogart movie this one i
found just on a whim it's called the
expendable man here it is that's the
cover the expendable man it's not a
super long read but oh
man is it terrific it is so good i have
to be honest the only reason i got this
book is because i saw that it
takes place in phoenix i'm from phoenix
the book starts out with a character
driving from l.a to phoenix for a
wedding this book just came into my life
at the right time because last year i i
went to so many weddings in arizona like
i've had to do that stupid drive on the
i-10 from la to phoenix so many times
i'm so familiar with that drive and
getting to see all the little stops
indio blythe all in all the places but
in the 1960s was fantastic oh my god
it's all of this aside if you've never
been to phoenix or la or whatever it's a
terrific crime novel there's kind of a
bit of misdirection at the start of the
book we start the book following a
character who picks up a hitchhiker
going from la to phoenix the character
has is very nervous about picking up a
hitchhiker she's a girl she's a young
girl and he's like doesn't want to get
in trouble in this situation and doesn't
want there to be any people to get the
wrong idea about what's going on here
and she keeps finding him in blythe and
trying to get further on the road with
him really isn't until page 50 that it's
said explicitly you can kind of
implicitly get this this this is why i
don't think this is a spoiler even
though they don't talk about it on the
book cover but i think it's important to
know and one of the one of the many
great reasons to pick up this book you
learn explicitly on page like 50 or
something that the main character is
black in all of the the ways that he's
behaving in this book stem from
the knowledge that he has that so much
could go wrong especially in a place as
backwards as phoenix in the
1960s he's a an intern a medical intern
working at ucla funny i go to ucla this
book just it's it's so relevant to me
his family is very well to do but he
understands that his reputation could
just be tarnished even if being the the
suspect in a murder case could tarnish
his reputation and of course what
happens the girl he takes to phoenix is
found dead and he is the main suspect
because he took her to phoenix just
because he's black has to do everything
above and beyond perfect in order to
just live a regular life dorothy b
hughes isn't she's not black but she
does a terrific job of going through the
psychological horror and the the the
terror that this man his name is hugh
has to go through and just the sinking
feeling of all of all of the wrong he's
just at the wrong moment at the wrong
time and he has to clear his name he
can't rely on the white lawyer he really
just has to rely on himself to figure
out who the real killer is there is some
stuff involving abortion that is very
very conservative of it and of its time
i was a little disappointed
because the novel is so
feels very ahead of its time in that way
but in terms of the abortion stuff not
so much it's so terrifically written
it's not super fast-paced but it's just
really methodical it feels so realistic
so well-realized and so
full the terror of feeling like
everyone's against you how you are
treated as expendable i mean hugh is
treated as an expendable person
he's getting this murder framed on him
on him simply because he's black i just
can't recommend it enough it's just
oh my god it's so good do yourself a
favor and look up dorothy b hughes
either read the expendable man
or i haven't read in a lonely place or
write the pink horse or any of her many
other novels if they're as good as this
one i mean i'm i'm definitely going to
be reading more from her and please i
urge you to seek her out as good as the
expendable man was it was not the best
read of this month the best read of this
month goes to surprise surprise
in old classic wuthering heights this
has been shitty this has been sitting on
my shelf for such a long time i just
wanted to give it a go and i was just
captivated from the first page going
forward like i don't know why but this
book is about hate this book is about
pure evil this book is about how there
are monsters in the world how monsters
are created and how those monsters
spread their evil to all those around
them i had a lot to say about this book
after i first read it which is why i did
a very long discussion
rant about this book on the second
channel and nadia's channel in a lot of
ways it's like the precursor to east of
eden which is one of my favorite books i
i'm gonna say i prefer this to east of
eden at least at this point it's full of
just so much and it has an incredible
pace considering it's covering
like decades of time in generations we
follow one generation and then the
generation that follows them with all
their screwed up kids incredibly done
the characters are like out of hell they
increasingly become more unhinged i
didn't think there would be so much
violence and abuse and just like torture
in in in one book and especially a book
that's supposed to be romance i think
people who who think of this book maybe
think of the first half where kathy and
heathcliff are in love and they're kind
of separated heathcliff is trying to get
revenge on her really this book is is
like mocking their their romance this
like insane the this intensity of their
romance where they're just wreaking
havoc on all the other people in their
lives there's one character who i really
loved and that was young kathy's father
because he he was able to move on and
care for someone else unlike any of the
other characters
in this book this book is all about how
love can turn into hate and how hate
just can destroy a human being
the characters have insane monologues
where they're just ranting and raving in
this like shakespearean
language the plot is terrific the
characters are so well realized you
don't really love any of the characters
but they are all so realistic but also
bigger than life it's it's the best of
both worlds there are people who hate
this book because of all the reasons i
adore it there's not really any heroes
everyone's really screwed up the more i
kept reading i was like this can't get
any worse like every time i said it
can't get any worse than this it just
kept getting worse for the characters
things just kept getting worse in their
lives and i felt so bad i was getting
depressed by the end in a good way like
it was is so moving if you haven't read
it
just check it out seriously but before
we move on i'm really excited to talk
about uh ren the sponsor of this video i
feel like ren is a very unique way to
look at how we are consuming ourselves
and how that affects the world and to
keep track of that ren is a website
where you can calculate your carbon
footprint then offset it by funding a
different mix of carbon reduction
projects like tree planting mineral
weathering and rainforest protection
just by answering a few questions about
your lifestyle you can figure out what
your carbon footprint is how to reduce
it it's a great way to just give back to
the environment and try to offset your
carbon footprint once you sign up to
make a monthly contribution to offset
your carbon footprint you receive
monthly updates from the projects you
support you get to see what your money
is actually spent on with photos and
details of every tree planted every acre
we forested every ton of carbon offset
it's actually been very eye-opening to
me to see what they're doing and i it's
it's genuinely really cool the first 100
people who sign up using the link in the
description will have 10 extra trees
planted in their name so seriously like
use the link it's there please use it
yeah well back to the video thank you
ren the next book i want to talk about
is a recent book from a dead author
called call me a cab this is the
so-called final book by donald westlake
even though they've been saying that for
all the books they've been releasing
basically this is one of the older books
that westlake wrote
that never got published because he was
insanely prolific and he could just
write all these books and just never
release them this is a terrific book uh
westlake is known for his comic uh crime
novel i've just touched the very tip of
the iceberg for donald westlake i am so
in love with this writer he wrote under
many pen names and he also wrote as
richard stark he wrote the famous parker
novel starting with the hunter it was
turned into point blank great books very
different from the style of donald
wesley and this is why i really love
donald wesley because he could write in
all these different styles he was so
prolific and he just oh my god there's
so much to dive into and he's just a
magnificent writer he's just so
incredibly good the prose level story
level everything i don't know if call me
a cab is his best work again i just
started diving into westlake but i read
this one recently it was recently
published by hardcase crime even though
it is not a crime novel i'm not
complaining though i thought there'd be
crime in it just based on the cover it
just starts with a great premise and
it's a road it's a road trip book it's a
rom-com starts off with a guy who picks
up a woman in his cab who looks a bit
distressed she says she has to go to la
to decide if she's going to marry her
boyfriend who is kind of putting an
ultimatum on her because she doesn't
know if she wants to marry him and he's
like hey you need to come visit me in la
and when you get here you have to decide
or else decide if she's going to marry
him and she decides instead of taking
the plane she's just going to take the
cab that she just walked into pay the
cab to drive her all the way across the
country from new york to la and so they
have this road trip story where
shenanigans occur talk to each other
this book was written in the 70s just
released now there's a lot of takes on
feminism and but again this is from a
man's perspective and written by a man
so it's there are dated elements but it
still felt very sincere and was quite it
was really good the characters felt very
real even though they're in this larger
than life situation that is quite
ridiculous but the suspense holds true
and this is what i think there were
great lessons if you're a writer in this
book in how to maintain suspense through
an entire book we're trying to figure
out is she going to decide if she's
going to marry this guy or not i won't
reveal anything else about the book i
will say it is a delightful fun read now
this gets me to the point where i
speculate about the stuff i want to be
reading and the kind of where my
headspace is at after this month i'm
hoping to have a little bit more time to
read some books and here are a few of
the books i've been interested in
reading i'm recording say hi to jacob in
the future oh hi jacob in the future
you're really handsome
whoa i'm including this i really want to
read oh and i i want to read some thomas
hardy because in class we were talking
about thomas hardy's poetry and then i
was looking into thomas hardy's novels
he wrote the mayor of casterbridge a
bunch of other books and i've been
watching a lot of books and things which
is a great channel you should check out
some amazing reviews on that channel and
i've been getting into victorian
literature especially after reading uh
wuthering heights but uh far from the
madding crowd i heard this is probably
the best way to get into thomas hardy i
oh i got this this isn't a book haul
video but i got this from the last
bookstore recently uh and it's signed by
lawrence block and this is the first of
his uh bernie roden bar mystery series
called burglars can't be choosers i'm
excited to read this then i got two uh
elmore leonard's old ones uh from the
80s i think uh so i'm gonna i'm gonna
check these out soon i got some more
lawrence block some more oh anthony
trollope i want to check out some
anthony trollope you know because i got
i got to get up to date with you know
all the all the stuff the kids are
reading a lot of older stuff oh and i
finally bought um the chalk circle man
which i really want to read and warlock
oakley hall i i picked that up not too
long ago i heard that's a terrific
western uh but it's pretty long so i'm
gonna need some time to set aside for
that other stuff yeah wheel of time i
want to cont i'm gonna continue reading
the wheel of time just my head has not
been in it lately why the wheel of time
is a little over saturated in my mind
lately it'll make a little more sense
later on so i haven't been reading it i
haven't been getting up to date with
those at all in fact i haven't been
reading much fantasy at all um
unfortunately and i i would like to
correct that i just
i don't know why i've been gravitating
towards crime and victorian literature
anyways once i graduate from college
i'll have way more time to read so what
else can i say i hope you're all well
thanks for watching this has been fun
for me to talk about and
all right bye-bye